confusingly we speak of love as one
thing rather than discerning the two
very different varieties that lie
beneath a single word being loved and
loving we can only make a relationship
work when we're ready to do the latter
and are aware of our unnatural immature
fixation on the former we start knowing
only about being loved it comes to seem
very wrongly like the norm to the child
it feels as if the parent is simply
spontaneously on hand to comfort guide
entertain feed clear up and remain
almost always warm and cheerful parents
don't reveal how often they've bitten
their tongue fought back the tears and
been too tired to take off their clothes
after a day of childcare the
relationship is almost always entirely
non reciprocal the parent loves but they
don't expect the favour to be returned
in any significant way the parent
doesn't get upset when the child has not
noticed the new haircut asked carefully
calibrated questions about how the
meeting at work went or suggested that
they go upstairs to take a nap parent
and child may both love but each party
is on a very different end of the axis
unbeknownst to the child this is why in
adulthood when we first say we long for
love what we predominantly mean is that
we want to be loved as we were once
loved by a parent we want a recreation
in adulthood of what it felt like to be
minister to and indulged in a secret
part of our minds we picture someone who
will understand our needs bring us what
we want be immensely patient and
sympathetic to us act selflessly and
make it all better
this is naturally a disaster for any
relationship to work we need to move
firmly out of the child and into the
parental position we need to become
someone who can sometimes subordinate
their own demands to the needs of
another to be adults in love we have to
learn perhaps for the very first time to
do something truly remarkable for a time
at least to put some
else ahead of us that's what true mature
love actually is much everyone's initial
surprise
you
you